[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a mother's plea to keep two men accused
of murdering her son behind bars
should gregory and travis mcmichael get
bond in the shooting death of a mod
arberry
amma wasn't allowed to go home
amal was even allowed the chance to live
a new review into the handling of the
jeffrey epstein case
this time it's the prosecutors that are
under fire
a defense attorney says the video you're
watching right now
proves a detective lied on the stand was
there a cover-up in this case
i definitely think there was we explain
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to long crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin a
father and son charged with killing a
man while he jogged through a georgia
neighborhood
will remain behind bars awaiting trial
gregory and travis mcmichael are facing
nine charges including
malice murder for the shooting death of
a mod arbory in february
investigators say gregory mcmichael
started chasing arbury as he left a
construction site
son travis mcmichael is accused of
actually firing the shots
a third man is charged with boxing
arbory in while filming the incident
the defendants claim self-defense
attorneys for the mcmichaels told the
judge the defendants deserve bail
because they're quote
good people who don't pose a flight risk
but brian a shocking jailhouse call
really helped the state
shocking indeed the prosecutors argued
that the mcmichaels hold views that make
them a danger to society
in a recorded call the defendant gregory
mcmichael said shooting a mod arbory was
in his words a good deed here's the tape
every minute i appreciate it well yeah
i just all right i can't i can't sleep i
can't
you know i got my mask on and everything
i'm trying to sleep but i can't it's
just
i wake up every 15 or 20 minutes you
know
you know you're bothering me you've
heard dale saying uh no good deed guys
unfunny
yeah well yeah that's it that's the best
example right there
later an emotional plea from the
victim's mother as she asked the judge
to keep the man
to keep her son's alleged killer behind
bars
during the course of the gbi's
secondary investigation
they discovered what they believed to be
one of amaz
bone fragments near where he was
murdered instantly shores
they wanted to know what we wanted to do
with those pieces of my son
that they were still discovering in the
streets
i have sat here and i've listened to the
attorneys for both travis
and gregory mcmichael their defense is
summed up
in an idea of grabbing their guns
chasing
boxing my son in with their vehicles
pursuing him and eventually
shooting him to death ripping his body
into pieces
these men are proud of what they've done
and they want to go home because in the
selfish minds
they think that they're the good guys
and i and my family is left literally to
pick up the pieces
the judge mentioned that video of the
shooting that we've all seen so many
times while ruling on bail
does not intend to respond
as to travis mcmichael or greg with
michael there's a big deal
you can interpret a number of rewards
if you give it to me tells me that
there's a
significant risk rather than here to the
community
so terry did mcmichaels ever really
stand a chance of getting out or was
this more of a way for the defense to
learn a little bit more about the
evidence prosecutors have against their
clients
well i do think the defense was fishing
for information but i have to say they
put on a good defense here they had a
number of witnesses
who testified that these individuals are
not going to run and in fact
the witness who had the best impression
as far as i was concerned because i
listened to some of them
was the landlord who said that she would
actually
give her entire house to the mcmichaels
if in fact they did not show up so
clearly the judge is probably going to
rule against the mcmichaels here because
you know
the seriousness of the crime but i do
think the defense stood a chance
and exactly that's exactly what the
judge did but brian
you can have good defense tactics and
strategy
but here the facts just were not on the
defendant's side
good people good deed these are not the
kind of words you want to be uttering
in a proceeding like this yeah it's not
a smart move here i understand that
many defense attorneys uh feel for their
clients and and so do i here
uh with mine uh but this is not the
language i think was going to work with
this judge in terms of asking for some
amount of bond or bail
and the facts and the evidence against
them was really stacking high yeah
exactly i mean you can do a good job as
an attorney but you can have facts that
just stack up against you and that's
exactly what happened here so
terry one of the family members
presumably the mother of the victim
was crying in the courtroom as that
video of the shooting played again just
another sad moment
yes it was very sad and in fact she was
afraid for her life she said she thought
if the mcmichaels got out
that she would be in danger that she
would be in fear so
i do think that that had an influence as
far as the judge was concerned
certainly and still ahead here on law
and crime daily a pizza delivery ending
with a strangulation
it's a trial we're following gavel to
gavel at law and crime but first
harsh words from the department of
justice for its own prosecutor's
handling of the jeffrey epstein case
did the millionaire pedophile get a
sweetheart deal
we're back in just a moment
[Music]
the justice department has completed its
review of the original botched
prosecution of jeffrey epstein terry
austin has that report now
terry erin the review of epstein's
so-called sweetheart deal
found no wrongdoing and no ethics
violations
by the prosecutor alex acosta who ended
up
in the trump administration but the
review did find that acosta used
poor judgment when he allowed the now
dead sex offender off the hook
former federal prosecutor and long crime
analyst gene rossi says
acosta's non-prosecution agreement with
epstein
was essentially an immunity deal
he didn't even get a slap on the wrist
he was saying we're not going to deal
with you
i have never seen in my 27 years with
the department of justice
an alleged predator like jeffrey epstein
preying on teenagers 13 and 14 years old
for which they had a boatload of
corroboration
it just wasn't her allegations you had
documents and diaries that corroborated
what they say
i am ashamed i am ashamed
that this prosecution agreement
non-prosecution agreement
was approved by the department of
justice
okay terry so alex acosta himself
released a statement saying the report
proves that he was within his authority
and that this was
not not a sweetheart deal do you agree
or disagree i disagree wholeheartedly
and i agree
with gene rossi this was a sweetheart
deal because
even if you are in your legal authority
he wasn't
in his ethical authority and as far as
i'm concerned
he allowed epstein who obviously was
alive at the time
to get off with a much lighter sentence
and he only served a
you know small amount of time and so i
think at the end of the day the
biggest ethical problem here is that
then prosecutor acosta
did not give the victims the rights that
they are entitled to and he totally
ignored them
and it almost made it seem like aaron he
was you know sort of
covering something up so that was his
biggest issue as far as i'm concerned
something was fishy about this so brian
nebraska senator ben sasse a fellow
republican
slammed acosta's actions as a disgusting
failure and said epstein should be
rotting behind bars so so i think that
that puts another point on this on top
of what gene rossi said
exactly i mean there's strong words but
the big difference between gene rossi
and the senator here
is that generosity doesn't have the
ability to move these thoughts into
actual legal
um power in the sense that this should
be something that we shouldn't just talk
about ethically
it should be something that prosecutors
are not allowed to do at all if we want
prosecutors to act a certain way in
these types of cases we've got to make
sure that laws
and uh procedures are set in place to do
so exactly prosecutors have a special
duty to ensure
justice that's in the ethics rules a
ballet dancer is under arrest on charges
she murdered her estranged husband
police in manatee county florida have
arrested this woman
ashley benefield they say she shot doug
benefield who was 30 years her senior
during an argument
ashley told police doug was attacking
her but the police say
the bullet trajectory suggests he wasn't
even facing her when she fired
celebrity attorney michael avenatti has
learned he'll go to trial on april 26th
on accusations he embezzled 300 000
from his porn star client stormy daniels
and for forging her signature
the money came from daniel's book full
disclosure which included mentions of
her alleged affair with donald trump
jury selection has commenced in an ohio
case we're watching engenet levy has a
preview
erica stefanko is accused of murdering
army veteran ashley biggs back in 2012.
biggs's body was found in a cornfield in
northern ohio
she had been working as a pizza delivery
driver prosecutors say biggs and her
ex-boyfriend
chad cobb were fighting over custody of
their daughter
stefenko and cobb allegedly lured biggs
with a fake order for pizza
and killed her cobb pleaded guilty into
serving life without parole he's agreed
to testify against stefanko
who is his ex-wife and we will be
carrying this case live on law and crime
once the testimony begins for law and
crime daily
i'm anginette levy and still to come
right here on the broadcast video of
police executing a warrant at a new
jersey home is proof
a defense attorney says that an officer
later lied on the stand we break that
case down
right after this
police approach a new jersey home use a
battering ram to bust down a door and
barge inside
surveillance video shows it took about
six seconds from the time the first
officer approaches the door to the
moment the battering ram slams the door
open
it looks like a typical drug bust but
this time the defense says it's way more
serious
because the defense says the video
you're watching shows that a lead
detective
lied on the witness stand i recently
spoke with defense attorney joseph
masrani about how he got his
client off the hook based on what he
alleges are the lies of the police
we see a lot of these cases and a lot of
times it's hard for us to find
proof to actually prove lies but in this
particular case we were able to
take me through your case what was your
client accused of doing
and how did the procedure roll out here
so client was accused of
selling marijuana out of
their residence it's it was a
multi-dwelling residence so it was more
than one family there
um so there are people living in the
basement people living upstairs
uh it wasn't just one uh one family it's
kind of unknown whether it was actually
our clients who were doing this or or
others living in that same
uh dwelling not connected to our our
clients
police obtain a search warrant after
conducting some investigation and the
search warrant called for the police to
first
knock and announce their presence before
entering the premises
and and that rule is is a very very old
rule
it predates the constitution police show
up and uh
they execute the warrant now when we the
defense
gets the initial reports we have it on
paper we read
and and the police and the police
officer in this particular case the lead
detective
indicated that they first knocked and
announced uh their presence
before then breaching the door and
entering the residence
as a matter of practice in in my
practice if i come into a case early on
early enough where i can send an
investigator out to see if there's
any evidence to show the police entry
or show who's out there or any type of
you know looking for things that may
help the case and kind of shed light to
see if the police did their job properly
or not
and it showed a completely different um
scenario or set of facts than what's in
the police report
uh so then we filed a motion to suppress
and during this
the suppression hearing the police
officer testified untruthfully by
basically saying
he walks up to the door with his um
colleagues behind him
uh and then he steps up on on the porch
uh knocks loudly with his big hands
waits 10 to 20 seconds or 10 to 15
seconds
you know depending on which version he
went with first or second
and then he knocks again and you know
during the knocks they announced that
police were there for the search warrant
and he said he did that loudly
uh and um once he testified to those
facts i got up to cross-examine him
knowing what actually did happen because
i
you know i have the the surveillance uh
video
and i started to question him about that
and
immediately i think he probably realized
that i have something that he's not
aware of
and immediately began to back up on his
initial testimony
so procedurally here this is what's
amazing to me the prosecutor is the one
who
originally elicited the testimony from
the police that this is exactly how this
went down
not knowing that you in your proverbial
back pocket have this video
that you're going to bring out that's
correct
the judge ruled that it was the
prosecutor's obligation to put on a
witness
to show that the execution of the law
was proper i wanted him to tell me his
version
open-ended i didn't want to i didn't
want to ask leading questions initially
and that's what the prosecutor did for
me
he told his version in an open-ended
manner and he was already locked into a
version by saying it on the record
when confronted prosecutors moved to
dismiss the charges
case closed not quite what happened next
attorney masrani believes
adds up to a cover-up that's when we
return on law and crime daily
a new jersey defendant beats a list of
drug charges when his defense attorney
discovers video
he says contradicts the testimony of a
lead detective
court transcripts say that detective
testified police busted down the door of
this building
10 to 20 seconds after knocking and
announcing that they were there
then that detective changed his mind to
10 to 15 seconds
this surveillance video shows it was
actually a five or maybe
six second pause but that's not all the
detective who testified that he was the
one who knocked
later backtracked saying he might have
been one of the people standing on the
ground
plus there are questions over whether
the video shows police
trying the door knob before knocking
prosecutors threw out the case but a win
for this defendant may mean
a loss for future defendants defense
attorney joseph masrani
claims prosecutors tried to block him
from making these issues known to other
judges
other lawyers and to the public
they dismissed the case that was the
first in my opinion that was the first
step of a cover-up
and then i sent a letter sent to the to
the cheat to the
head of the office who was the acting
prosecutor at the time saying hey this
happened this needs to be investigated
and and it got investigated according to
them
but as you see from the letters that you
have they found that
that the allegations were not sustained
meaning that no wrong happened the
officer did not lie the officer did not
do anything wrong
to me the actions that they even took
afterwards by attempting to stop me from
distributing this information to other
defense attorneys and other judges
speaks of a cover-up from from the
dismissal of the case in the beginning
to the very end in your opinion did the
officer lie on the stand
absolutely and if you were
the person sitting in the seat of
judgment in this case what do you think
should happen
procedurally to the officer to the
prosecutors uh
and anyone else involved i don't think
the prosecutor that was
dealing with the case
um knew right
he just took the word of his officer
which is what
generally happens in every case
prosecutors and officers work together
day in and day out
you know we're all human beings
friendships develop sentiments develop
towards other people and we don't want
to believe
that this particular officer is is not a
good officer or is lying or is your
personal cuts corners
so i ca i really can't blame that
particular prosecutor
for for anything he did i do blame
higher-ups in his office for
dismissing the case and not allowing the
judge
to make the proper credibility findings
against that officer the prosecutor's
office refused repeated requests by law
and crime to discuss the case
defense attorney masrani's request for
an internal police investigation
involving alleged false testimony ended
this way
the investigation failed to prove or
disprove your allegation
the officer was found to be in violation
of department rules and regulation
and will be disciplined and receive
training
despite that finding attorney masrani
says this little case has big picture
implications
they basically took the side of the
officer that he remembered
incorrectly which is if you look at the
transcript
it's obvious that that's not what
happened and
uh and then basically that he didn't lie
he just got confused which is
a very easy defense uh
when you're dealing with a secret
environment of internal affairs
investigations
the conversation happening around the
country right now is one of holding
police accountable how does this case
fit within that conversation
this is actually the perfect case for
that conversation because in this
particular case
that officer there is no sustained
non-credibility finding against them and
there's no ia
internal affairs uh non-credibility or
truthfulness finding against them so
he's clean
brian let's talk about the bigger
picture here knock and announce what's
the legal standard police must follow
when they're executing a warrant
so every state is different but the way
they all come down to the same issue is
when the judge tells you how to execute
a warrant whether it be no knock or
knock and announce you have to follow
those procedures the judge hands down
here we're being told that didn't happen
they were told to do one thing and
decided to do another and that's
improper based on the information they
gave the judge
so terry there are such things as no
knock warrants but they're supposed to
be hard to get
does it disturb you that the video
purportedly shows the police trying to
mess with the door knob before they
knocked or at least that's what it looks
like it shows
it's very disturbing aaron and in new
jersey a no knock warrant
has to be you know proven obviously
beyond a
probable cause that they can go in there
and the best way to get the evidence
is to go in there without knocking and
it is supposed to show
that it's you know sort of making sure
that the
officers are protected so unless they
can show those two things
they shouldn't really have been issued a
no-knock warrant and interestingly
enough in new jersey
they do have a bill now pending to end
all no knock warrants and it's very
similar to what's going on
across the country so we'll see what
happens to that yes and brian that
officer has a clear record
it's hard for defense attorneys to find
this information
yeah because it's not printed anywhere
there's not going to be a transcript of
a trial because they dismiss the case
there's not going to be information and
if we do have the list of bad cops as we
do in so many states
he's not going to make it to it and so
therefore this issue this problem
just going to happen another day it
makes your job a lot harder as a public
defender
exactly and that's our broadcast here on
law and crime daily thank you so much
for joining us we appreciate it
law and crime daily with brian buckmeyer
and terry austin continues next time
right here on the law and crime network
we have much to discuss when it comes to
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you